Well, I was a little disappointed in the extremes,
or rather, it didn't work for me.
Besides, just manipulating cold water won't break the devil's horns, so
why do you want to hone this technique
?  I
didn't have the means to become stronger, so I
got a pregnancy medal.
Nah, but I think I'll be able to use it to my heart's content here No matter how much I try to swing the blade around,
you're the only one who'll die
gen 2
That's what
this kind of power is good
for, isn't it meant to break the demon's horns?
It's a goal,
you eight owe it to
me It certainly seems to be true in the olden days
Beyond the corpses of Early and others, you can
see the supplies clad in the murky colors of the East
Music] It's
you I
've been honing my skills to cut
you Sounds
like fun